i thought here it is
so first off
i'm going to read this and first off
let's start with things that totally
happened
oh god oh god i just oh god i haven't
read it's great it's really good
no no we get through this let me put it
over here so we can see it better
um
so this is from an article that she did
for ellie l l whatever this
chick magazine is uh senator kamala
harris
oh this is so cra i already read ahead
uh i know what part you read around oh
my face hurts i know what you read
already
uh senator kamala harris started her
life's work young
she laughs from her gut the way you
would with family as she remembers being
wheeled through an oakland california
civil rights march in a stroller with no
straps
with her parents and her uncle at some
point she fell out from the stroller few
safety regulations existed for
children's equipment back then
thanks ralph nader ralph nader editing
this article
and the adults caught up in the rapture
of protests just kept on marching
by the time she by the time they noticed
little com
camila was going was gone and doubled
back
she was understandably upset my mother
tells the story about how i'm fussing
she talks like that now harris says and
she's like
baby what you mean what do you need
and i just looked up at her and said
[Music]
freedom
i just looked up at her and said
freedom
freedom i
i i can't say any of the things that i
want to say right now
well before you do and before you do let
there's a little more of this story like
before any i can't i'm my brain is
cycling through and all of the things
that are going through my head i'm like
i couldn't even utter this you could sit
in your car while you're driving i guess
yeah it's that it's that fair
hey you know what the worst part is this
goes back to what i said yesterday
i'm all for the new world order now
which by the way i'm still waiting on
that application boys
hit me up anytime i mean you guys can
just like
you have my phone number right like you
just call me from like
an unlisted number told me to meet you
somewhere i'm still waiting on my nwo
invite
uh i understand now i understand that
people because
because a bunch of women are gonna read
this and they're gonna go isn't that the
greatest
oh my god and i have one more thing to
add to this if you don't mind
it's worse yeah it's worse turns out she
stole it
from a 1965 playboy interview with
martin luther king jr
where he wrote
i will never forget a moment in
birmingham when a policeman accosted a
little negro girl
seven eight years old who was walking in
demonstration with her mother
what do you want the policeman asked her
gruffly and little
the gruffly and and asked her gruffly
and the little girl
looked him straight in the eyes and
answered fetum
she couldn't even pronounce it but she
knew it it was beautiful
hi i'd like to feel this if i could uh i
actually was that little girl
oh no um so i could understand the
confusion but uh
i was actually the little girl that
inspired dr king oh really so that was
but but wait a second
no i wouldn't she she said oakland and
he said birmingham i
wouldn't put it past kamala harris to
look
dead in the eyes of whoever was
interviewing her and tell that
bald-faced lie
no i was a little girl actually dr king
was very inspired by my early work
so she stole it from and by the way
nobody's gonna care
do we we're we we do realize right at
least that like these people
can do whatever they want and if they
[ __ ] up or if they get caught
it's fine they just do it again like
there's no there's no
there should be consequences for these
sorts of things
i think we all agree right that there
should just be like
not even in politics just in real life
when you tell a story like that and then
somebody goes
yeah you sure you didn't lift that from
dr martin luther king
from 1965 like even in your group of
friends
you should be ridiculed out of the room
oh i i already have the sure i have a
consequence for her i already have one
she has to be a hundred percent
considered just fifty percent okay die
like that
consequences freedom who is your
favorite freedom do you think your
indian side
is very racist against blacks it has to
be they don't really don't yet i don't
i will not rent to these people they are
destroy your property
but who was your favorite freedom
fighter um
there's so many of them who was there
one guy from the mujahideen
um mine's robert e lee who's yours
mine's uh
al baghdadi oh nice good pick
what mine's al zakaria
sorry i mean you know whoever whoever
the whoever the al qaeda and uh
iraq guy was mine's mine's al borland
from home improvement yeah
um
that is yeah i'm fine but how is there
no like
how do you not shame people like this i
don't understand it
well i mean yeah on this show oh
everybody else we're not exactly gonna
derail the presidency we're not gonna
stop the steal royce
yes we are how are we going to do that